Ches 9 6 96 I had such a good experience
with that I can't play it staffer gambit
what are we getting into now g3 can i
play a halloween halloween let's do it
halloween the other time reverse this is
probably not a good line but i'm doing
it anyways if 94 f5 almost actually it
does trap the night and if night
somewhere else on maybe queen d5 queen
g5 Queen f3 e4 this is interesting
playing a reverse Halloween trying to
make it work
calculating this this oh there's Queen
b3 not the end of the world it's going
to be annoying though Queen b3
maybe I'll just slide over if founds in
White's face calculating this I hang
upon ladies queen c8 in the hands
probably not that great trying to make
this work though Bishop c5 in White's
just restricted ooh I should attacking
us 7 I should probably just gambit that
7 pawn I would be happy to open that
file Bishop d6 perhaps should be g6 and
then king d8 play Bishop d6
to avoid this check so I don't want
Queens to come off I'm ready to play
this and target f2 okay Queen f6 both in
d3 threatening Bishop g5 you I don't
know how I deal with that I have c6 so
maybe it's not that bad
d3 c6 it's weird when a 5 b6 I just want
to chase the Queen away from the
covering the square Queen takes e4 all I
forgot about that move I'm to be down a
piece and queens are getting traded but
I'm still alive kind of so I'll have
some initiative I have to create some
attacks somehow a3 expected I'll win the
pawn so how many pawns do I have I've
one pawn for the piece hmm AB d3 perhaps
looks questionable but it's a move you
should see for Bishop g6 Bishop c4 I can
maybe take it's like b5 there's a 5 king
D 7 just controlling the square for the
Knights with Bishop maybe C 5 C 5 C 5 C
4 ideas oh no C 5 was terrible oh it's
still down on so many levels I'm losing
another piece oh I have this move though
maybe it's not so bad
attacking this I'm forking a bishop and
the fork which would fork the other
bishop in the rook and kind of the pawn
but not really
opponents thinking that's what matters
there's still hope a sliver of hope keep
thinking think for another minute
there's a d5 good move
how much am i down I'm only down a rook
by a pawns majestic pawns let's play a
six this nice how the play which is good
let's move the knight towards the center
and get ready for c4 d3 invincible pawn
chain um yeah let's do it
I might even trade off I'll get rid of
that night invincible pawn or maybe just
d3 or the way take stakes let's activate
the King it's to push d3 at the right
moments don't want to allow unnecessary
sax King d5 King power okay now let's
move that's a good move if I push mmm
let's push time scramble time play this
move it's a passive defense but
necessary defense let's play f5 and then
94 getting this oh there's a fork but he
missed it
in 97 let's move over and then go in for
the kill let's see - coming where's my
win I don't see it to push more pawns
before c3 coming ooh that's gonna fall
it's not gonna be pleasant oh it didn't
take it thanks for the raid oh no this
is really bad
Oh Fork this is really good meat coming
no not coming thirty minutes
just for my speed claw thinking yes
what is he him another dirty flick Oh
somehow I made that work kind of
opponents burned enough time early on I
thought I was coming back at some point
like I I like my chances after see - is
there so much danger if I didn't see the
just like there should be something here
maybe there's not I mean I'm still down
the rook Whitehouse counterplay might be
three or look-see - it's for the bit
Slough HS dude u s-- mode i gained three
rating points for that okay maybe I'll
put that on YouTube YouTube people hope
you guys have not died of a heart attack
and if you haven't liked the video
subscribe and I'll see you in the future
for twitch I have some rating points
still to gain let's go back and let's
play I have not lost a stream maybe I'll
put the whole stream on YouTube who
knows it's 103 a.m. I need to get my
laundry this might be my last game sadly
but maybe truthfully oh I'm playing the
same person wait what was it oh the
person who I just played okay
that's person's probably seeking revenge
and didn't reach quits hello people from
YouTube we come in peace scream laundry
it's the critic comment okay I'm gonna
try and get the same person twice with
another Halloween gambits
I said this move it's just smooth I
believe I should know theory by now but
usually I just wing it the same way I
wing the wing gambit now this one I
think d6 I can Queen f3 d5 wait d5 I can
take that
maybe Knight takes oh then Bishop e6
let's see with Bishop my opponent might
know what he's doing
hmm it's kind of annoying takes
yeah because d4 is a bit weak but tender
what to do takes with mm-hmm not seeing
an attractive option here it's probably
good variation let's take and play
Bishop b3 now maybe 90 92 is better
that's okay there's there's a little bit
of comp I have two pawns
what's castle or let's play 94 nice
square for the knight not a 5c three
Queen d5 maybe Queen g4 get pawns are
kind of pleased I'm not losing a nice
play this move play this move preventing
block from castling kingside
have this idea - should have considered
that sooner maybe rook F for harass the
Queen
that's a good move hmm let's just triple
up I still have all my pawns have five
ideas it's not that bad
twin g4
anticipating g5 meeting g5 was f5 also
is preparing d5 that's annoying let's
play this move or this mmm it's like we
need to trying to keep control before
ideas before it b5 ideas there should h4
I'll play 94 want to play a 4 B 5 and
not sure what a 6 and h6 are are doing
still want to fight B 5 make the knight
move somewhere less desirable quite
naive for the ships not so hot
no offense regaining my time lead time
lead regained b5 incoming open the a
file and put a rock on a one almost b6
okay let's put the rock on
the only open file g5 order G I played
Queen c4 mmm let's take it
you didn't see anything better the queen
g4 here the Queen here maybe Queen here
it's risky
Queens you 696 does that work it might
work it might not work
let's make c5 someday very tricky
position between d5c for kind of traitor
the weakness but it's ok ah ok pawns are
smiling just what I need
night is passing down and nights but
it's okay let's put the Queen on g5 and
middle pawn up on time
Oh Knights trying to escape no escape
Queen defends 'if I've what's a 5 let's
take a pawn attack my rook let's play
this everything's defended these squares
are covered let's play this move pawns
are in his face pawns are marching let's
play that first and then you 7 coming
what a position look at this position
pawns everywhere check double promotion
for mates why the game what a game
the same opponent apologies from to my
opponents both of those games
Halloween gambit but thanks for the
games
tense it's hard to play like the sort of
gambit against a strong player
thanks for the bits again rice Rockets
could he have forged queen and rook I
mean in the end my pawns were rolling
could he afford sweetened milk yeah like
in this position there's going to be
pawn moves so Knight c2 just runs into
ticks in review thanks so much
Nicole it's too soon Alexandra botas
Alexandra bow ties with her resub thanks
so much
Alexandra boat s solving for five months
London champ I have not been playing the
London the stream I've been playing okay
I played to Halloween gamuts and it's
the same opponent back to back I play
the butas gamut earlier thanks love hey
chess um so this will probably also go
on YouTube I don't know if I'll put it
with the same video as a previous game
yet to be determined but for you to
people again if you're still alive like
comment subscribe
tweets Instagram posts share someone
tagged me in a video on Instagram their
baby was watching one of my videos on on
an iPad it was really cute